one you know breath away from the
presidency is Kamala Harris there's a
campaign that the ABS the administration
waged against her very very clear and
they've acknowledged this in sort of
back Channel ways of New York through
New York Times through the Wall Street
Journal in Washington Post saying that
she's terrible at this I mean you saw
all these stories she's bad at this but
they got her as the Veep now and now
it's turning and now everyone's saying
well you know we have to put her out
there after Defender I think that the
Border stuff was bad for Republicans of
course that's number one that's what it
is you know what it is they gave her
that they said the Border no one can fix
it you take it so she so she got
associated with a problem that would
take more than just the vice president
that was not good and also she could
have talked about it differently yes she
could uh because the Democratic party
like many left-wing parties all over the
West they've been entrapped by the work
mind virus you've been talking about so
you can't talk about immigration if
you're on the left because you're afraid
of the people to your left right you're
afraid of saying you're racist exactly
right and and we have this problem in
England where I live we have ethnic
minority uh politicians who are
attempting to deal with this issue
they're still being called racist you
can't deal with it properly and that's
why she's been saddled with it I mean
Bernie Sanders used to be one of the
most virulent immigration
restrictionists and his argument was
that it it's it's it suppresses
working-class wages which is an argument
some economists make he's backed away
from that in recent years and I think
that's why it's not just Bernie Sanders
it's Bill Clinton it's Hillary Clinton
it's Chuck Schumer it's all the
Democrats and it's all the people in
England just the same on the left
everybody used to agree that countries
need borders and for some reason we've
forgotten that
how does
I feel like both parties could win so
easily
they would just if they got rid of the
two people they're running
your monologue and